بدون محاكمه علانيه عازله نفذ النظام
الايراني عقوبه الاعدام بحق الشاب محسن
الشكاري في اول عمليه اعدام على صله
بالاحتجاجات ثم يبدو انها رسالته ترحيبيه
من النظام في اوجه التساع النطاق
الاحتجاجات والاضرابات التي عمت مدن
البلاد وبدات بالفعل تثبت نجاحها والخشله
النظام في وقتها كما يقولون مراقبون
[موسيقى]
النظام الايراني
باغلاق الشوارع وجرح عنصر من قوات الفسيخ
اثار هذا القرار رد فعل واسع داخليا
وخارجيا المحتجون هددوا بالانتقام
والتصعيد في مطالبات منظمه حقوقيه بمواجهه
قرار النظام بردي فعل قوي على المستوى
الدولي محاضرين من اصدار المزيد من احكام
الاعدام ضد معتقلين الانتفاض الايرانيه
كما اسماؤها ولكن من هو محسن شكار الذي
كان على اول قائمه الاعتمامات
[موسيقى]
ياباني
وفي ردود الفعل على الاعدام وصفت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا بربوك وصفه
المحاكمه بانها خادعه وسريعه واعتبرتنا
تنفيذ النظامي للاعدام يعكس ازدراء الى
حدود له الانسانيه بينما ادانت فرنسا من
جانبها باشد العبارات هذا القرار وقال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه قال ان
عمليه الاعدام تاتي لي تضاف الى انتهاكات
اخرى خطيره وغير مسبوقه
[موسيقى]